here we are Quentin what do you make of
the idea that this is the golden age of
television can movies compete um yeah
well I think this it's it's definitely a
really great age for television right
now I don't uh I kind of I tend to think
of the 70s as the golden age I think
this is a new Silver Age frankly to tell
you the truth um but uh yeah the golden
age of television was the 70 well I grew
up in the seventies and I really I
really liked the show's back then you
know like like Hunter no that's that's
the a that is the ad that's different
than Jake in the federal estate yeah
what do you only wait James Garner what
was that one a Rockford Files lab that
was the good yeah you know why you want
me well Frank I mean frankly to tell you
the truth I actually get a little tough
so that's better than The Sopranos well
let me tell you let me tell you how I
feel about it in one ways it's like
funny because in the city it would
always bothered me in the 60s and then
the seventies and shows where you'd have
an episode and was such a one-off that
nothing that ever happened on that show
ever affected it ever again all right I
mean how many times did Little Joe fall
in love and then she would die at the
end of the episode and she was never
brought up ever ever again even though
that time it was really love I liked it
better that way now we okay now we have
arms yeah now we've earned a pendulum
completely in another direction where
now everything is a soap opera
everything is a serial drama if you
didn't watch the first episode or the
second episode you're completely lost
can you imagine if they miss everything
previously on bonanza yeah
okay David Frum is jeb Bush's candidacy
salvageable great question um it was
never salvageable
yeah and uh and and the book didn't help
well the book is an example of why
because people when when Jeb Bush got
asked the questions about Iraq he
stumbled and fumbled and and there was a
queue of people offering helpful
suggestions about what to say but there
was no answer and look I I was involved
this administration I was a supporter of
the Iraq war and president the elder
President Bush had some discipling
things to say about some of us were
involved with that and I have strong
feelings about all of that but the the
key fact about this story the situation
for the Republican nomination is we owe
the the new nominee of our party whoever
it is the chance to be his own or her
own person with his or her own story not
beholden to the recent past and that's
why the Jeb Bush candidacy was was a
mistake from the start because it turned
the 2016 election into a referendum on
things that happened a decade and a half
ago and that's not fair to anybody it's
not throw to the voters it's not fair to
the candidate it was all a mistake and
he's a crummy candidate he quit on me
he's just crummy he could if their hit
was unsolvable problem support yeah like
he's not that bright
that's an unsolvable problem he's not a
bright guy he's not he could have been
end result on Ronald Reagan rolled into
one but he wasn't of the problem now he
wasn't he wasn't either of those that he
didn't help right okay Anthony Weiner
given his affiliation as an independent
is Bernie Sanders an appropriate
standard bearer for the Democratic Party
well it is a big question he hasn't
really answered yeah I would have this
conversation with him on the floor all
the time I'd say you know come join the
come join us need say no I'm not a
Democrat I don't believe in what do you
guys you guys are doing it all wrong and
I said yeah and then and now he's gone
and now and that's my Larry David
impression and now
but now he's gone to saying I don't not
only want to be part of the party I want
to be the standard-bearer for the party
and there was a practical reason he's
doing it you really can't get elected as
a socialist or an independent but it
does kind of eat into his authenticity
thing I mean he's got to say look I'm
not really a Democrat but I'm doing it
to get elected and I'm not doing this
thing for and I'm doing it for pragmatic
use caucus with the Democrats no no he
totally by the way I love the guy I mean
I mean I love you and I and you know
he's and his used on single-payer health
care I believe is the right thing to do
and he got the Iraq war right I got it
wrong that's not the point the point is
of this question is one that I've
actually puzzled it a little bit the guy
is really this authentic guy and the
bottom line is he's making this
practical decision to do it and he's not
this this pure guy that doesn't do
anything it seems like a minor point as
far as political compromises go this is
way down totally totally but I I is no
question okay and he is also the second
best candidate for the Democratic
nomination
so I there you go
Gillian how has no Gillian has the
refugee crisis in Europe created a human
trafficking problem absolutely I know
why they're asking you that but I'm sure
you can answer any question I actually
did just get back from Austria and
Hungary and Serbia and Croatia how
they're asking um yeah it definitely has
because you have kind of I'm sorry
Gillian's mom has no
so you just got back yeah and to spend
some time reporting on both the
government side of it in the refugee
side of it and I think what we have
right now basically is a situation where
Germany has said come we'll create a
life for you you have opportunity here
and countries on the periphery out of
very valid concerns about security about
economics have been a little bit more
hesitant and that dissonance is creating
a situation where it's the perfect
business opportunity for human
traffickers they could not have it
better I don't know why we don't create
a some sort of system where we could
train them to then go back to their own
country and fight for that country
doesn't somebody have to stay in the
Middle East and make the Middle East a
place to live not everybody in the
Middle East can can live in Europe
that's true but I think people are
looking at frankly America's commitment
to this you see countries like Ukraine
where people are well what about their
own commitment to their own culture I
think they're profoundly committed to it
I talked to one really why are they
leaving well I talked to one Syrian guy
young guy and he was basically saying
that he feels pinched in the middle he
doesn't support Assad he's gonna get
cracked down on that side he doesn't
like the Islamic state either he doesn't
have weapons he doesn't have you know
people to fight with what's he gonna do
find other people to fight with I mean
where where are all these moderates I
always hear about this is you know Bill
Maher you're so hard on the Muslims what
about the moderates I'm all for the
moderates they're for me too by the way
real moderates yeah
so let's get a moderate army together I
don't think we have a lot of support for
them though I mean look at what's
happening in Ukraine right now you have
people who are organized who are willing
to fight for their country and die for
their country and the u.s. can't even
like give them weapons and help them out
a little bit when Russia refugee crises
are about the powerless right people who
were refugees our general gun was
powerless people around the old idea of
all if you were tougher yeah I don't
know if that's not yes I'm just saying
why don't we help them but not everybody
who is a moderate in the Middle East can
leave the Middle East giving it I mean
that there just isn't room is there no I
think we need to be doing more to help
those moderates right okay
let's see what does the panel think of
Isis taking responsibility well that's a
good thing responsibility for the
Russian airliner that exploded of the
Sinai this week what are the two sides
to that what are the two answers that's
well on a bad leg they did it yeah it's
bad that they did it if they did it and
it's a horrible thing that happened and
I mean I think it's I mean I don't know
what the other it it's not exactly a
yell fest question is it's I don't know
and this is not always a yuk fest
especially we're not even on TV and it
gives a [ __ ] I only do this because I
have talked about your new movie look
they're all ready to see it it's yeah
this is another Western yeah this is
strange to me cuz you last one was a
Western I've never known you to do two
in a row of the same genre you're you're
Kubrick a skin that you like one movie
doesn't replicate along what why two
westerns in a row well one I love
westerns and two part of the thing is
you know you for that almost exact
reason you're talking about you do the I
do I do something like Kill Bill where
I've never done a martial arts movie
before and then you kind of learn how to
do it by the course of doing it actually
is part of the fun I'm like like in Kill
Bill I didn't know exactly how I was
gonna do the crazy 88 fight scene that
happens in there but I figured but if
you commit to doing it and you'll learn
and you knew it would be violent yeah I
didn't know that I did know that but the
thing is though in the case of Django
was I learned how to do a Western I
learned how to deal with the horses I
learned how to deal with the Wranglers I
learned how to deal with all that stuff
and I loved it and so then it came time
to do another film and it was like whoa
now that I really know how to do a
Western let me do it again
I think I can even do a better job so
what's this what can we expect in this
one well this is uh it's actually that
well but again the hateful eight it's a
hateful they will go to play on the
Magnificent no no no I don't know it's
you know it's not has to think of the
Magnificent Seven when we I can buy
Canuck whoa I can understand that if but
it's not about a
a team that comes together to do
something together it's it's eight
people who are totally [ __ ] hateful
yeah there's no part of the thing about
the movie is there's not a good guy or
woman in it they're all there's no
heroes there's it's it's like eight
hateful people trapped in this one stage
code stopover during a three-day
Blizzard and watching them deal with
their issues so it's kind of a it's kind
of a pick-me-up holiday kind of and
let's go say and it opens on Christmas
bloody Luther that's why white people
are killing themselves
thank you very much everybody
you